l'estival une véritable tradition à
maurepas
depuis ce lundi 2 août bac à sable tir à
l'arc tennis de table ou encore jeux
gonflables ont pris place dans la cour
de l'école dé baissière il y en a pour
tous les goûts et tous les âges
il ya un tapis pour eux ou glissé après
tu vas dans un bassin yanggu flag et il
ya aussi un autre goût flammes
je vais pas les activités d'aujourd'hui
mais tout ce que je voulais faire un
autre jour un jour nos efforts à bout un
rendez vous habituel pour certains
parents et leurs enfants un fils qui a 9
ans et demi là qui est venu exprès là
avec sa copine pour profiter des
vacances à maurepas estivale et akamai
d'activité ici aujourd'hui donc elles
vont en profiter pendant tout le mois
d'août on va essayer si beau temps est
là entre les points de restauration de
repos ou encore les activités sportives
en groupe de 14 heures à 16 heures
chaque jour
tout est fait pour profiter du moment
entre amis ou en famille c'est important
parce que tout le monde n'a pas la
chance de partir en vacances
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
ça permet aussi de prolonger les
vacances pour ceux qui ne partent pas
sur la totalité des vacances scolaires
et comme point d'orgue du mot repas
estival son concert de clôture en
nocturne le vendredi 27 août prochain